quoi
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
je veux que tu restes avec moi pendant
la purge avec zahia et pourcel pour ce
toxique l'attaqué ton frangin je te
promets je vais faire la bcc
nécessaire
ouais
tu vas faire quoi le torturer tuer c'est
toujours ça toi ta solution
la violence c'est toi ça
aujourd'hui c'était deux personnes qu'on
connaît mais tous les jours il ya des
gars qui finissent à l'hosto à cause de
toi des jets pas faire autrement
j'ai grandi dans la zone comme toi on
doit tous faire des choix dans la vie
gay et roux blessé et a choisi dernier
la purge
c'est qu'un seul jour toi
dimitri
tu détruis notre communauté et les 364
jours tristes cette nuit permet aux gens
d'évacuer toute la haine qu'ils ont
accumulés en oeuvre ça ne te rendra pas
ton fils merci
c'était une nuit qui caractérise
mes chers concitoyens ce sera une
tradition que nous célébrerons chaque
année participé à la première purge
cette expérience controversée de
l'égalisation du creem et appelé la
purge rester avec moi pendant la pure
chanson sortira tout ça
annonce le lancement de
toutes les voies légales pour les tous
visite d'état de son bien alors qu'on va
devoir protéger
il faut préparer au pire courage
jégou sharif
[Musique]
ouais
des bienfaits de la purge